solo tiene siete años pero sara maneja
el hisopo de algodón casi como una
profesional bájate el tapabocas y ve
despacio como si estuvieras buscando
mocos en alemania- el autodiagnóstico en
las escuelas es obligatorio desde que
terminaron las vacaciones de semana
santa dos veces a la semana bajo la
supervisión de un profesor es como si
estuviéramos en clase de química sabemos
si estamos sanos o no es genial y no
duele tan solo esta escuela realiza 1300
pruebas a la semana y ha encontrado a
tres niños con kobe de 19 años no tenían
síntomas así que sin las pruebas nunca
lo habríamos sabido
hacemos las pruebas por nuestra propia
seguridad la gran mayoría de los
profesores no están vacunados y no
queremos acabar en las unidades de
emergencia queremos trabajar y que los
niños vuelvan a la escuela pero no todos
están contentos la asociación de padres
de la ciudad está luchando porque los
exámenes obligatorios se hagan en casa y
las críticas vienen de los padres
profesores y algunas administraciones
escolares que dicen que no se puede
controlar que es demasiada obligación y
se pierde tiempo de enseñanza
alemania es el segundo país en europa
que introduce los autos diagnósticos en
las escuelas
austria fue el primero y su experiencia
sugiere que hay motivos para ser
prudente en berlín más de 800 niños
dieron positivo en kobe 19 la semana
pasada los colegios tendrán que volver a
cerrar por completo si la tasa de
incidencia de la ciudad supera los 165
casos por cada 100.000 habitantes